- Les habitants du quartier de
Shevchenkivsky n'avaient pas
encore tencore tencore terminé n
quand ils ont d'abord été
éblouis par une lumière blanche
puis, projetés par
une explosion.
Ils savent que les combats se
sont rapprochés de chez eux,
mais à l'instar de Yura,
ils ne veulent pas partir.
"Bien sûr! Dire qu'on n'a pas
peur, ça reste difficile, mais
c'est normal maintenant.
On s'est habitués."
Certains des habitants
s'étaient réfugiés ici après que
leur village ait été occupé par
l'armée russe. Pour d'autres,
c'est le souvenir d'une guerre
qu'on croyait ne plus jamais
revivre qui a été ravivé.
Valeri a survécu à l'occupation
nazi, encerclée par
les Allemands.
"Pendant des mois, nous avons
vécu dans un village encerclé
par les Allemands. Nous les
voyions, mais les Allemands
n'ont jamais fait ce que
les fascistes russes font
maintenant."
Elles ont largement passé l'âge
de devoir prendre les armes.
Mais ça ne les arrêtera pas,
dit Valentina.
"On va se défendre. J'ai
des bocaux de confitures.
Je vais les prendre et les
frapper sur la tête."
Ce n'est pas pour elles
qu'elles s'inquiètent, dit
Ludmilla.
"Je ne peux pas penser au mal
qui pourrait arriver à
mes enfants et petits-enfants.
Je ne peux pas imaginer
qu'ils puissent mourir alors
qu'ils commencent à peine à
vivre. Et ces bâtards les tuent.
Je veux que Poutine, ce bâtard
meurt et se retourne dans
sa tombe."
Chose certaine, c'est qu'après
un mois de guerre, la Russie ne
ménage pas la population civile,
ici un complexe d'appartements
encore bien habité et derrière
moi, un jardin d'enfants.
Des cibles militaires.
Par contre, autour, on n'en voit
pas.
Cet homme a été transporté
d'urgence dans un grand hôpital
de la ville après la frappe de
ce matin. Il est sur la table
d'opération depuis plusieurs
heures. Son pronostic est
sombre.
"Nous avons arrêté l'hémorragie,
mais beaucoup de signes font
croire qu'il ne survivra pas."
Ici, il ne reste presque plus
des patients réguliers ou de
malade chronique. Du jour au
lendemain, le personnel soignant
s'est tourné vers la médecine de
guerre.
Pour que des patients comme
Valera puissent être sauvés.
"Nous allions à Vinnitsa chez ma
grand-mère, mais nous n'y sommes
pas arrivés à cause des Russes.
C'est parce que notre voiture a
explosé. Nous ne l'avons pas
atteint."
Valéra et sa mère Natasha
fuyaient la banlieue d'Irpin
avec un convoi de voitures
identifiant clairement
qu'elles transportaient
des femmes et des enfants.
Mais l'armée russe a tout de
même tiré ses obus.
"Ce qui se passe actuellement,
c'est un génocide intentionnel,
c'est la destruction de tous
les russophones et ukrainiens.
Nous avons tous beaucoup de
monde en Ukraine. C'est
pourquoi. Je ne pense pas
qu'il y ait d'options. La Russie
a juste besoin de sortir."
Natasha est russophone.
Son père est Russe. Ils
n'avaient pas besoin d'être
secourus par la Russie,
dit-elle. Aujourd'hui,
elle voudrait fuir, mais redoute
de pouvoir être sauvée.
"J'ai peur, mais je ne peux
aller nulle part physiquement."
Aujourd'hui, ils sont quelques
300 civils à être soignés, comme
Natasha, à Kiev pour des
blessures de guerre en plus de
16 enfants comme Valera.
Depuis le début de la guerre,
plus de 300 civils sont morts
dans la capitale selon
la mairie. Quatre enfants ont
été tués.
"Encore combien devez-vous voir
pour arrêter de soutenir
la Russie? Avant de l'isoler?
Chaque cent qui va dans
le budget de la Russie va servir
à acheter des armes qui tuent
aujourd'hui, et dans
les dernières semaines,
nos hommes, nos femmes et
nos enfants. Combien de crimes
de guerre en plus voulez-vous
voir? "
Les frères Klitshchko ont
l'habitude de se mesurer à
d'imposants adversaires. Quand
la Russie a envahi l'Ukraine,
beaucoup ont cru que
les défenses de la capitale ne
feraient pas le poids face à
l'armée de Vladimir Poutine et
seraient vite terrassées.
Un mois plus tard, Kiev réussit
encore a essuyé les coups, mais
il ne faut surtout pas baisser
la garde, dit l'aîné, Vitali,
maire de la ville. La Russie
pourrait encore leur infliger le
sort de Kharkiv ou de Marioupol.
"Nous espérons que non,
mais nous savons que ça peut
arriver à notre ville si
la Russie attaque et détruit
toutes nos infrastructures et
la capitale de l'Ukraine."
Les lignes de front bougent
peu. Au nord-ouest, les forces
Ukrainiennes ont su rendre
les coups. Mais plus à l'est et
au sud, la Russie se rapproche.
Ils ne seront pas assez nombreux
à se battre si Kiev doit arriver
à se relever avant le compte.
"La mission de chaque homme est
de défendre les familles et
les enfants. Les hommes qui ont
conduit leurs enfants en
sécurité doivent revenir pour
prendre les armes et défendre
la ville. "
Kiev restera Ukrainienne,
promettent-ils. Mais la ville
n'a pas fini de transpirer et de
saigner dans la bataille.
Ici Marie-Ève Bédard,
Radio-Canada, Kie